Salut romain
mais qu'est-ce que tu es en train de...
Pardon mais les toilettes sont loin et comme on est pressé. Je me suis dit que...
wouaa.. tu as mangé des asperges non?
mais comment tu sais, t'es médium?
pas besoin
Quand on mange une banane, notre pipi sent le pipi.
Quand on mange un concombre notre pipi sent le pipi.
Alors pourquoi quand on mange une asperge notre pipi il sent l'asperge? Bah ça c'est...
La question que tout le monde se pose
Tout commence par un repas normal.
Avant le dessert il y a eu un plat en sauce, avant le plat quelques asperges trempées dans la vinaigrette.
Rien ne laisse présager du drame qui se noue en silence.
Quelques minutes après avoir quitté la table pourtant,
Frédéric LeGroutar se rend aux commodités.
Il fait face à l'horreur
la plus plus absolue.
Son pipi
sent l'asperge.
comment tout a basculé en un instant? Pour comprendre il faut remonter aux origines de la tragédie
Quand on mange une asperge, comme quand on mange n'importe quel aliment, elle se retrouve très vite dans l'estomac où elle est dégradée
par des sucs digestifs
des acides des enzymes etc... les différents composés issus de cette dégradation sont ensuite absorbé par les parois du tube digestif
et se retrouve dans la circulation sanguine pour nourrir les organes
et le reste finit dans les urines après avoir été filtré par les reins. Dans le cas qui nous intéresse
l'asperge contient de l'acide asparagusique qui est dégradé en composés qui contiennent du soufre
comme le méthanéthiol et le sulfure de diméthyle. Et quand on fait des dosages après avoir mangé des asperges
on se rend compte qu'on retrouve ces composés très rapidement dans les urines à des taux mille fois supérieur à de l'urine classique
et ces substances en plus d'être éliminées très rapidement dans les urines, on parle d'une quinzaine de minutes, elles ont la particularité
d'être très odorantes. le méthanéthiol par exemple fait partie d'une famille de composés organiques qu'on retrouve dans les pets,
dans le liquide qui est sécrété par les putois, et qui sont aussi
utilisés pour fabriquer les boules puantes, et aussi la substance qu'on ajoute dans le gaz que vous utilisez chez vous pour lui donner une odeur
particulière qui le rend plus facile à repérer en cas de fuite. Car à la base le gaz n'a pas d'odeur
on parle du gaz domestique celui pour faire chauffer l'eau, on est d'accord
alors je sais y en a parmi vous qui ne se sont jamais posé cette question tout simplement parce que
vous n'avez jamais remarqué que votre pipi sens fort après avoir mangé une asperge
on peut formuler trois hypothèses à ce sujet soit vous ne mangez jamais d'asperges et vous ne reniflez jamais le pipi de ceux qui en mangent
soit votre pipi ne sent pas l'asperge quand vous en mangez, soit votre pipi sent l'asperge mais vous ne vous en rendez pas compte.
il n'y a pas grand chose à tirer de la première hypothèse donc on va se concentrer sur les deux autres
et il se trouve qu'il y a plusieurs chercheurs qui se sont déjà penchés sur la question. ah c'est un beau métier chercheur
le résultat de ces différentes études, parce qu'il y en a eu plusieurs, c'est que les deux dernières hypothèses
sont valables: certaines personnes produisent une urine qui ne sent pas l'asperge après en avoir mangé
on ne sait pas pourquoi... et d'autres personnes ne détecte pas l'odeur des asperges dans les urines
alors qu'elles contiennent pourtant les fameuses substances odorantes dont on a parlé. Pour le coup ce serait dû à une variation génétique
de certains capteurs de l'odorat. Maintenant vous savez. DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui si vous avez d'autres questions de ce genre
envoyez les moi à l'adresse questiondtc@gmail.com on se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos
d'ici là prenez soin de vous, prenez soin des autres, mettez-vous bien et surtout
portez-vous bien